[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICCARDO GOVONI: [INAUDIBLE].
LYDIA FITZPATRICK: Are we ready?
RICCARDO GOVONI: Yeah.
LYDIA FITZPATRICK: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our talk on
the fact that no one
likes crashing or janky apps.
I'm Lydia.
I'm a technical program
manager on Android.
RICCARDO GOVONI: And I'm
Riccardo, engineering manager
on Google Play.
FERGUS HURLEY:
Hey, everyone, I'm
Fergus, product manager
for Android vitals.
Hands up here, who
likes one star ratings?
OK, we got one person
who's in the wrong talk.
I'm sorry, but the people who
don't like one star ratings
are in the right place.
So we're here to
tell you how you
can engineer your app
for high performance
with the new tools available
on Android and on Google Play.
We're going to start off by
talking about why performance
matters in general.
And then we're going to
jump into the new initiative
that we have around
Android vitals,
and how we've simplified it for
you to be able to understand
and take action
much easier by using
the concept of bad behaviors.
Then we're going to jump into
how you can detect and fix
these issues most effectively to
be able to have successful app.
Great.
So for the people who want
to avoid those one star
ratings, the number
one way you can
do that is by focusing on
stability of your applications.
We put Google's machine
learning to work
to be able to figure out, what
are people talking about in one
star ratings?
And we found that 50%
of one star ratings
are talking about
stability and bugs.
Then, once you fix
those issues, how
can you get to a five star app?
What we found is that, if you
want to get to a five star app,
focusing on design,
usability, and speed
are the things that matter.
Because 60% of five star reviews
are talking about those topics.
But don't just take our
word for it, or more likely,
Google's machine
learning words for it.
You need to actually take
developers' words for it.
The Busuu team, which has built
an amazing language-learning
app found that, by
focusing on performance
and making that a part
of their culture, they
were able to increase their
star rating as a result.
The Big Fish Games
team have even
seen increases in retention
by focusing on performance.
At Google, and specifically
within Android,
we're obsessed with our
performance and device
performance.
We've been obsessing over this
for a number of years now.
Back in 2012, we launched
Project Butter with Jellybean.
Since then, we've launched
the Doze mode, Project Vulkan
last year, and this year, a
bunch of new tools in Android
O, and the ability for you
to be able to get insights
with Android vitals.
So what is Android vitals?
You might have seen this in
the keynote earlier today.
This is our new initiative
to be able to help
you be able to gain deeper
insights into the performance
of your application across
core performance metrics.
The three that
we're starting with
are stability, battery,
and render times.
You'll see many more
come over the course
of the next few
months, and we'll
be able to give you
those insights on Android
and on the Play console.
So let's jump into the three
that we're launching today.
First one is stability.
So everyone knows that you
shouldn't have your app crash.
People have been focused on
this for a number of years.
And at crash analytics
have introduced the concept
of crash-free users.
Now in the Play
console, you can be
able to see your user
rate and your crash rate.
You can also be able
to see your ANR rate.
And this is where your--
ANR is a concept
on Android, which
is Application Not Responding.
That's when your app
appears frozen, and does not
respond for five seconds.
The next area is battery.
So this is where we want you to
avoid using people's devices,
and consuming their
battery inefficiently.
So is where we want to avoid
using the radios, or using
the CPU when you
shouldn't be, and you
don't need to, actually.
The next area is rendering.
So this is where we want to be
able to help you understand,
how can you provide a silky
smooth experience to your users
so that they feel like your
app is smooth and fluid
on their device.
And we have two
metrics that we're
going to introduce you
today that can actually
help you be able to deeply
understand that area.
So we're talking about three
major performance areas here.
And within each
performance area,
we're going to be
introducing two metrics.
It's a lot of data to be able
to understand and consume,
so we've simplified it to
this concept of bad behaviors.
This is where we take your app,
and we study the performance
data on it, and we
figure out, if you're
in the bottom 25% of apps
according to that metric,
we flag it to you
and say, hey, you
need to improve in this area.
Let's do a show of hands.
So if-- let's say
5% of your users
are experiencing that
50% of their frames
are taking more than
16 frames per se--
and 60 milliseconds to render on
the screen, is that a problem?
Hands up if they think
that's a problem.
OK, great.
So lots of people agree that's
a problem, and lots of people
don't agree that
that's a problem.
Well, we will actually
tell you in the console
when you've reached the boundary
of when that's a problem,
and you're in the bottom 25%.
Right now that's at
about 2% of users.
Impacting-- experiencing that
rate will actually be flagged,
and that is putting
you in the bottom 25%.
So we're really trying to
simplify it there for you
so you can be able to understand
where you are positioned
according to the benchmark.
So where do you see this data?
You see this data in a
new top level navigation
item in the Play console
called Android vitals.
It's live right
now to all of you.
And if you have
enough data, you'll
see the insights that
I'm talking about,
and that Riccardo is going to
tell you more about right now.
RICCARDO GOVONI:
Thank you, Fergus.
So as Fergus just said, we
just launched a new section
in the Play console which
is called Android vitals.
And it is available
to all of you today,
and you can go and
check it out now.
What it does, it
summarizes all the findings
that we have about
your app performance
across these three
domains that Fergus just
mentioned-- stability,
battery, and rendering.
It works out of the box
without any integration needed.
Not is the case to add--
nothing to add to your APK size.
The data that you find there
is collected from millions
of Android users that
have opted in to share
diagnostic information with
Google to help all of you
understand and improve
the quality of your apps.
Android vitals also highlights
wherever, at any given time,
there is a problem that
affects a significant fraction
of your users.
For example, you can see one
of the red marks over there
to indicate that you should
be looking at your rendering,
and understand if there
is an issue there.
And so you can use these
as the first port of call
to understand your
application performance.
So we're going to
spend some time now
to go into detail about
all these three domains--
stability, battery,
and rendering.
I'm going to start
with stability.
Stability is about crashes
and ANR reports, Applications
Not Responding.
Until today, the
only way for an ANR
or a crash to surface
in the Play console
was if your users explicitly
acknowledge a dialogue
on the phone for each ANR
and crash to be reported.
And this obviously
tedious, and it
led to low volume of
crash and ANR reports.
So the first thing that we
have done with Android vitals,
we have greatly
reduced user friction.
As I mentioned, the
data that you find there
comes from users
that had opted in
to share diagnostic information.
Opt in typically
happens only once
when a person
activates a new phone,
and that is a very
low friction gesture.
So this means that
in the Play console,
now you see over
100-fold coverage
in the number of
reports, with the reports
coming from users running
versions of Android as old
as Jellybean.
And this reaches 98%
of the Android devices
that have Play
services installed.
So let's start with
the first domain--
stability.
What are the bad behaviors
that we want to flag out there?
Crashes and application
not responding,
which is application freezes.
For sure, you never really
want any user of your app
to experience one of them.
And so we define
these bad behaviors
in terms of percentage of
users that are experiencing
any of them in any given day.
You may be familiar with
the equivalent metric
that other crash reporting
tools have introduced,
crash-free users.
And so for the next
few minutes, I'm
going to focus on
ANR specifically.
What is an ANR?
ANR means Application
Not Responding,
and this happens when your
application freezes, and stop
responding to user input.
This could be because
you have a deadlock
in your multithreaded
code, because you
have a UI thread
which is too slow,
or because you have
background receivers that
do not complete within a
meaningful amount of time.
ANRs are super disruptive
of the user experience,
and therefore you should aim
to never have any of them.
And because the application
is frozen during an ANR,
it means that you cannot
typically used a crash
reporting SDK to collect them.
On the other side, the Android
platform tracks all of them
automatically.
So they're all available in
the Play console without you
having to do anything at all.
We just got today
Android vital section,
and in there you will find a
tab which is called ANR Rate.
Here you can see how many unique
users experience an application
not responding when the app
was used on a given day,
across versions,
device, and OS versions.
And if the fraction of
the user is significant,
you get a red highlight
to drive your attention
so you can focus on the
most prominent issues
and dive into the details.
You can click the
related ANR section.
And in there, you
arrive in the ANR
and crashes section
of the Play console.
Here, in addition to reviewing
your overall crash failure
rate and ANR rate, you can
dive into each crash and ANR
that has been detected
for your application.
Android collects ANRs and
crashes almost immediately
as they occur.
So here, you find crashes
and ANRs that are typically
a few minutes old, at most.
There's a bunch of
little new features.
For example, we highlight
when a given ANR
has been introduced for
the first time in your most
recent app version with those
little orange highlights
to help you track the
quality of your last release.
You also get to see the
number of unique users
that have been affected
by that particular ANR
so you can distinguish between
high volume issues that
are affecting only
a handful of users,
versus widespread
ones that might
be affecting a significant
fraction of your user base.
You can dive into the
details, and observe
how the number of reports and
the number of affected users
trends over time, and
how it breaks down
across device versions,
OS version, app versions.
And obviously, you also
get the full thread dump
that captures the
application state
at the time the ANR occurred.
And for crashes, obviously
you get similar functionality
where you get the stack
trace that was observed
when the crash occurred.
So I think this gives you
a pretty good information,
visibility into what is
happening on your users' phone.
The next step is to try and
reproduce and debug them.
What I recommend is
the new Android Studio
3.0 that has plenty of new
profiling capabilities.
The new Android
profilers in Studio 3.0
provide real time data
about your app CPU, memory,
and network activity.
And I think this is
a great next step
to debug your ANRs,
because root [INAUDIBLE]
them often lies in not taking
into proper consideration
CPU intensive operation,
or blocking operations
like fetching data
from the network.
The CPU profiler, for
example, gives you
a real time CPU usage for your
app process on a timeline.
You can dive through
instrumented method traces,
and understand which methods
in-- maybe in your UI thread
are using up most of the
time, and become blocking.
Similarly, the network profiler
display network activity
on a timeline, showing
data that was sent,
received, and
associated latencies.
Again, you can use these to
understand if a slow network
call is making your threat
blocks for a response,
and because of an ANR this way.
And as Steph showed
in the keynote before,
it's very easy from
here to jump directly
into the code that is
responsible for that network
call.
If you want to learn more
about the studio profilers,
there's a great talk tomorrow
morning in Amphitheater
that I encourage you
to go and attend to.
OK, now we discussed how to
review how many ANRs you have,
how to debug them.
But the thing is, how
do you prevent them
from happening in
the first place?
Textbook recommendation,
Android 101 is,
do not do blocking
operations in the UI thread.
And use, for example,
a sync task instead.
You can use StrictMode to catch
accidental disk or network
access on the application
main thread as well.
Another common case is when you
have a broadcast receiver that
receives an intent, and
does not finish processing
within a window of time,
which is around 10 seconds.
Or your broadcast
receiver gets a sync,
but you forgot to call
finish on the pending result
that you get back.
Again, this Android 101,
very simple examples.
Most likely your code is much
more complicated than this.
You may be using
queues, asynchronous
operation, libraries
like Rx Java.
The basics do not change.
The same recommendations apply.
Be mindful of
which threads are--
on which thread the callback
for your asynchronous processing
and dump executing on.
Use semantics in
your coding practices
that make sure that you don't
end up executing accidentally
on UI threads when you
don't want, and so on.
Finally, be mindful of
introducing deadlocks
in your app.
And be it because you go
and check the ANR trackes
that you're collecting when
the device is connected
to your PC when you're
doing debugging,
or by downloading the tracing
from the Play console.
You can easily spot
if, at any time,
you have deadlocks by,
for example, looking
when a given thread, like the
UI thread here, is locked,
waiting for a background
one, and vice versa.
So that's all I had
to cover about ANR.
But a fundamental
question remains--
how much do they matter?
How much should you care?
And the answer is, you
should really care a lot.
We look at the apps that have a
high and low crash rates imply.
High crash rate-- more than 5%
of users experiencing a crash
or in an hour per day.
But what we find is that
these apps have 30% more
uninstallation in the
first day than apps
that have a low crash rate--
less than 1%.
So the message is
pretty simple--
if your users find your
app and they experience
a crash, most likely they will
leave as soon as they found it.
I will now hand over to Lydia
for battery and rendering.
LYDIA FITZPATRICK:
Thanks, Riccardo.
Android users care a
lot about battery life.
In fact, making
it through the day
without needing to
charge their device
is a top concern
for Android users.
Because of this,
the Android platform
has spent a lot of time building
features to save battery.
One of the number one ways we
can conserve power and battery
power is by putting the
device into a deep sleep when
it's idle.
This means powering
down the CPU, radio,
and other components that
would otherwise drain power.
However, you, as
application developers,
can prevent the device
from going into deep sleep
and conserving power.
One of the ways you can do
this is through wake locks.
Wake locks keep
the device awake so
that it can perform an activity
on behalf of your application.
There's a couple of different
types of wake locks.
The first is a full wake lock.
This keeps the screen on.
And this is usually used by
a video app or a gaming app.
Because the screen
is on, the user
is going to be aware that
wake lock is being held,
and in full control of
powering down the app
and saving their battery.
There's another kind
of wake clock, though.
This is called a
partial wake lock.
A partial wake lock
doesn't keep the screen on.
Because of this,
the user doesn't
know that the wake
lock is being held.
And so, if a partial wake
lock is held for too long,
it can become a silent and
deadly killer of battery power.
Because of this, we
defined a bad behavior
around stuck partial wake locks.
We define a stuck
partial wake lock as one
that's held for over an hour
by a significant percentage
of your users.
The Android vitals
dashboard will show you
how you're using, and
possibly abusing, wake locks.
It will show you
the distribution
of how long wake
locks are being held
by each version of your app.
In this example, you
can see the majority
of the wake locks are being
held for a minute or less,
which is ideal from a
power saving perspective.
However, there's a
long tail of wake locks
that are being held
for over an hour, which
meet our definition of bad
behavior, or stuck wake locks.
And so you can see
that we flagged
this app for this bad
behavior in the Android vitals
dashboard.
In the Android vitals
dashboard, we'll
give you the
information you need
to debug your stuck wake lock.
Most importantly, the
name of the wake lock.
In order to prevent--
to protect user
privacy, we will only
show wake lock names if it's
been used across many sessions.
This will prevent the leaking
of any personally identifiable
information.
Because of this, I encourage
you to use standard wake lock
names for each distinct wake
lock in your application
in order for them to
be debuggable in case
they become stuck wake locks.
The reason that we're
highlighting stuck wake locks
in the vitals dashboard is
because of just how dangerous
they are.
I mentioned in Android we care
a lot about conserving power.
So every day, we collect reports
from internal Google users
who have experienced
a bad battery day.
A bad battery day is
one where your device--
the battery doesn't last
as long as it usually does,
or as long as you
expect it to do.
So they'll send
us these reports.
We did some analysis
across a two month
period of all these
reports last summer,
and we found that 30% of
these bad battery days
were caused by stuck wake locks.
I think this highlights really
how dangerous wake locks are.
They cause real
problems for real users.
Because of this.
I encourage you to avoid
using wake locks entirely.
Wake locks were introduced in
the early days of the Android
platform.
And since then, many
of the use cases
for which you
needed a wake lock,
you no longer need
a wake lock for.
For example, if you're doing
a long-running download,
you can use the Download
Manager instead.
If you're synchronizing data
with an external server,
use a Sync Adapter instead.
If you need to run a background
task, use the Job Dispatcher.
And if you're
holding a wake lock
so that you can process an
intent before the device goes
to sleep, use the new
Job Intent Services,
which is being released in
the Support Lib V. 26 that's
coming out later this quarter.
Both Job Dispatcher and
the Job Intent Service
are compatible with the
background restrictions
that we're going to
be rolling out in On.
So it's a win-win.
You get a background check--
a background restrictions
compatible service, and you
don't get any stuck wake locks.
So definitely check
out Job Intent Services
in Support Lib V. 26.
If you're unable to use
any of these alternatives,
and you need to use a wake
lock in your application,
I'll rehash some of the
fundamentals from CS 101,
because they're
just so dangerous.
I'll spent some time rehashing.
First is, keep the logic
around your wake lock extremely
simple, because any
errors in the logic
could lead to them
getting stuck.
Second, try to do as little
as possible while you're
holding this wake
lock so that it
doesn't need to run
for an hour or more
to do whatever operation
you're holding it for.
And finally, use
defensive error handling.
You can see in
this example here,
if I hadn't defended
against my cleanup task
throwing an exception, the
release method on my wake lock
would never have gotten called,
and some poor user, or perhaps
millions of users, would end
up with dead phone batteries.
So if you follow all
my advice and are
able to not use any wake
locks in your application,
I still want you to go
check out the Android vitals
dashboard for stuck wake
locks because it's possible
that services you
depend on are using
wake locks under the covers.
For example, the network
location provider wake lock.
In this case, it's used
by millions of apps
to find a user's location.
If you're using it
too aggressively,
it could hold wake locks for
an extended period of time
that become stuck, and
you get flagged for that.
So in this case, you would
fix that suck wake lock
by throttling back the amount of
calls you make to this service.
So definitely
check out this tab,
even if you're not
using wake lock,
so you can tune how you use the
services under the covers that
might be using wake locks.
The second way you, as
an application developer,
can prevent the phone from
going into a deep sleep
and saving power for users is
through the use of wakeups.
Wakeups are alarms
that you can fire
outside the lifetime
of your application
to wake the device up
to do some sort of task
on behalf of your application.
If you do this excessively, the
device won't be able to rest,
and you'll end up
draining a lot of power.
So we've identified a bad
behavior of excessive wakeups.
We define frequent app
wakeups as a percentage
of users who are impacted by
wakeups that occur more than 10
times per hour.
Just like wake locks,
you can get a full report
on the wakeups that you're
using, or possibly abusing,
in the vitals dashboard.
And just like wake
locks, you'll see
the distribution of the number
of wakeups across sessions.
And you'll be able to see
the names of each wakeup
so you can debug any
frequent wakeup issues.
And just like wake locks,
we'll only show the wakeup name
if it's seen across
a lot of sessions
so that we don't leak
any personal identifying
information.
So again, be sure to use a
standard name for all wakeups.
A lot of people use the
pattern of firing a wakeup
to get the device awake,
and then holding a wake lock
to keep the device
awake so that you
can perform some sort of task.
This is a double whammy
of possible bad behavior
because you might be waking
up the device too frequently,
and your wake lock that
you're holding may get stuck.
So let's get rid
of both of these.
A much better alternative
to wakeups and wake locks
is a Firebase JobDispatcher.
The Android platform itself
does have a job scheduler,
but I encourage you to use the
Firebase JobDispatcher because
of its backward compatibility.
In the Firebase
JobDispatcher, you
can set up a task to
run as a repeating task.
For example, I can run
this every 30 minutes.
Dialing back the frequency
that you're running the task
is a first step to
save some power.
So 30 minutes is certainly
better than running this
every 5 minutes.
However, you can also
constrain the job
to run only when
it's on a charger.
This is obviously the
ultimate battery saver
because it wouldn't ever run
while the user's on battery.
Here at Google, a lot of
our apps employ this method.
For example, Play Store
will wait to update--
auto-update apps until
you're on a charger.
This is because we understand
a user would rather
have a device that lasts
through the day than a latest
update of some apps.
So I encourage you to use
that same very critical lens
when you're considering
scheduling jobs.
See if it can wait until
the device is on a charger.
The final bad behavior
we'll talk about today
is render times.
Render times measures
the amount of time
a frame drawn by
your application
takes to actually get rendered
on the screen hardware.
Render time directly correlates
with how users perceive
the performance of your app.
Android devices render
at 60 frames per second.
This is based on
the refresh rate
that's available in the
screen hardware itself.
If you do the math,
60 frames per second
breaks down to having to render
a frame every 16 milliseconds.
So as long as your
app is rendering
a frame every 16
milliseconds, users
will feel that your app is very
smooth, very fluid, and very
pleasant to browse.
If your frames take longer
than 16 milliseconds,
even just 17 milliseconds,
it will get dropped.
If you have a lot
of dropped frames,
your application will feel
very stuttery, very jarring
to users.
So you want to minimize the
number of dropped frames
that your application has.
If you drop many frames in a
row, and you get to the point
that it's been 700
milliseconds before you draw
the next frame in
your application,
this is the point
at which users will
think your app is
unresponsive, and they'll
begin to feel frustrated by it.
You should aim to have
zero frames that take 700
milliseconds or more to render.
We've used both of
these thresholds
to identify some bad behavior.
The first is slow rendering.
We define this bad
behavior as the percentage
of users who experience more
than 50% dropped frames.
The second bad rendering
behavior are frozen frames.
We define this as the
percentage of users
who experience more than 0.1%
of their frames being frozen.
The Android vitals
dashboard reports
on both of these metrics,
and will flag you
if you're excessively slow in
rendering, or too many frozen
frames.
Just like wake
locks and wakeups,
you can see the distribution
of wakeup-- of rendering times
across sessions.
And the dashboard will also
give you some other statistics
that help you understand what
might be causing your rendering
issues.
For example, I can see a high
percentage of slow UI thread
activity.
This indicates to
me that I'm probably
trying to do too much
work on the UI thread.
So I should move
things like disk I/O,
or network activity to
a background thread.
These statistics, though,
are pretty high level,
and they'll just hint at the
root cause of your rendering
issues.
To really understand what's
causing your rendering issues,
you'll need to dive deeper.
You can do this in three steps.
The first step is to
instrument your app
with the
FrameMetricsAggregator API.
This API is built on the
FrameMetrics API that
was released in Android Nougat.
The FrameMetrics API collect
statistics about how long
each frame takes to render.
The FrameMetricsAggregator
API, as the name suggests,
aggregates these statistics
across a series of activities
that you define, and you define
the start and the endpoint
of that collection.
So you can collect
statistics about how long
specific workflows in your
application take to render.
Once you've done
this step, step two
is to get this data
off the device,
and upload it to the
cloud or your servers
where you can then analyze it.
You'll analyze it to find what
flows are rendering slowly
for the majority of your users.
From there, you
can move on to step
three, which is getting
your device out, walking
through those flows, all the
meanwhile recording a trace.
Once you've reproduced
that slow rendering
behavior or those frozen
frames, you can upload that
trace into Systrace
which will tell you
exactly what was going
on in your application
when that slow
rendering occurred--
and not just your application,
but what was going on
in the system as well.
From there, you can
figure out which
specific code paths you need to
optimize to fix your rendering
performance.
I've just skimmed the surface of
the FrameMetricsAggregator API,
as well as Systrace.
Luckily, you have two
more opportunities
to learn more about them.
This evening, Tim Murray,
who's an expert on Systrace,
will give a talk
on how you can use
it to debug rendering issues.
Tim has analyzed
over 1,000 traces,
and is a true
expert in the field.
On Friday, you can go learn
from Chris and Chet, the authors
of the
FrameMetricsAggregator API
about how you can use
it to really understand
your application performance.
And with that, I'll give
it back to Fergus to close.
FERGUS HURLEY: Thanks very much.
Thanks, Lydia.
Great.
So today we introduced
three performance areas.
We have many other
performance areas
that we're going
to be introducing,
as I mentioned earlier,
over the course
of the next couple of months--
app startup time,
memory, and network use.
For each one of these
performance areas,
we're going to
introduce bad behaviors
so it's really easy to
understand the metric,
and how you're doing in that
metric compared to other apps.
A lot of the tools we've talked
about, especially on the Play
developer console side for
the Android vitals dashboard,
aggregate over your whole APK.
If you want to understand within
your APK specific performance
areas, I'd encourage you to
use the Firebase Performance
Monitoring tool.
It was launched earlier today
at the developer keynote,
and it enable you to be
able to instrument your app.
Out of the box comes
network and startup time,
but you'll also able to
use your own counters
to be able to track
whatever you would like
to track in your application.
There's a talk on this that's
going to happen tomorrow,
and I encourage
you all to attend
that to learn more about how you
can be able to use the Firebase
Performance Monitoring
SDK in your application
to be able improve performance.
So we covered a lot today.
We covered why
performance matters.
We covered Android vitals, and
introduced the new concepts
around bad behaviors,
and the six performance--
six bad behaviors.
And again, those bad behaviors
are high ANR rate, high crash
rate, excessive wakeups, stuck
wake locks, slow rendering,
and frozen frames.
We introduced the
Android vitals dashboards
within the Play console.
We talked about
the Android Studio
3.0 profilers, and
the Android APIs
that are available for you.
So if you're not motivated
by all the things we talked
about around
performance today, I
encourage you to
come to our talk
tomorrow where we can give you
a Buzzfeed-like talk on why
should you care more
about performance
with all the Play console
tools that we have available.
So one of the things that
we're going to talk about
in this talk is the
rewards that the Play Store
is going to offer you for being
able to improve the performance
of your application.
We'll get more into
the details there.
But we're going to
start using performance
data in the promotability
within the store.
Another reason why you
should care about performance
is, we have 2 billion
users on Android right now.
It's a lot of users.
Lot of users using their
devices to make emergency calls.
If you improve the battery
life of your device,
and you're-- of the device
itself by improving the battery
life of your app, then users'
device will last longer.
They'll be able to make more
emergency calls, and be--
you're basically, I'm going to
go out on a limb and say it,
saving people's lives by
focusing on performance.
RICCARDO GOVONI: [LAUGHS]
FERGUS HURLEY: Great.
Maybe stretching a little
there, but hopefully you get it.
Great.
Thank you very much, everyone.
I really appreciate
joining today.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]